oh my God it smells so good oh my God
it's the coconut thing okay okay great
to see you obviously you know Eva yeah
they're tired of me no what we're in
love with her as everyone is so wait so
you guys you play a married couple in
flaming hot we just saw that beautiful
scene so tell us about your characters
um okay me first
um I play Judy Montanez
um Richards a long time devoted partner
um
she is
his backbone essentially you know behind
every strong person you gotta have a
right hand man and I think she knew the
power partnership and she really she
played that well said yeah I think that
describes your character perfectly what
about you uh I play Richard montañez and
he's the he's the legend that helped
create the the flame yeah snack ever
best one of best-selling snacks ever
with uh with she's always grooming me
yeah
[Laughter]
Jessie's fantastic in the movie I mean
so funny both of these are I can't I was
crying watching them walk out I know
even like watching that little scene
it's such you do such a great job of
selling your health chemistry is so
great in the movie is it true though
Annie that you you used to watch Jessie
when you were a kid I was in love with
Jesse as a child oh my God that sounds
weird and you got to play no it doesn't
it was me and Steven Tyler
um yes so that's amazing though and then
you get to work with him and not only
work with him but play as significant
other that's cool I like I said I was
amongst two legends like I got the Eva
obviously have been looking up to her
for forever and just her Brilliance
comedically and seeing that she was
director and then directing this and
then Jesse I'm was in the middle of this
like
I all of my dreams are actualized like I
to be able to be in a story like this
where you have this man's dream to come
actualize and for me to live it I'm like
there's something happening in the
cosmos and I'm here for it
your eyes are like mesmerizing by the
way yeah they're so beautiful I'm like
it's hard not to stare so if I look
weird sorry
um so how did you start acting Jesse I
was uh second grade my first acting
experience I played I don't know if you
know the story no so you know the old
like the the winter coats that have the
fleece on the inside we turned it inside
out so that we could turn that into a
bear costume if we put construction
paper it may bare ears and like I was
the Bear in like my second grade play we
made this paper brown paper cave that I
would jump out and Sage my line that was
your line that was your line that was it
and I nailed it yeah
then I took a Hiatus for like 30 years
and then he booked this movie so cool oh
my God
I wanted to do this I was oh yeah that's
pretty cool to have that not everybody
has that yeah right off the bat you know
yeah I'm really I'm really grateful and
really lucky that I get to be in the
industry that I'm in but yeah I was a
little kid daydreaming about and I you
know this and I would get in trouble at
school my mom would come in to class I
would think I was in first grade and
she's like what are you daydreaming
about one day when I'm gonna be in the
movies and he's like well you need to
learn how to read I'm sorry you're gonna
have to go to read the script yeah yeah
yeah yeah so Eva do you remember your
first role that you ever did well I was
an extra for a long time and I didn't I
didn't have that I didn't grow up
wanting to be an actor it was like I
graduated from college and I was like
I'm gonna be an actor for my mom I was
like I'm the disappointment of my family
they were like oh geez here it goes but
no and then when I moved to Hollywood I
was an ad was an extra for like two
years and I loved it I was the one I was
like I'll do it I'll cross I'll be it
I'll do it I'll be there like somebody
needs to pour the coffee I'll pour I'll
pour the coffee and they're like can
somebody get rid of this girl anyone
else like the girl that girl's on set
again
that was me that's awesome though but
yeah I once I was like that I was like
so curious about everything and always
about behind the camera not so much in
front of but like what is that guy
what's that guy doing why is he standing
there what are you doing they're like
there's an extra on the set again that's
what I find interesting that you are
involved in both because I'm like even
like for me like I don't really get into
producing so much like with vocals or
doing anything like that I like the one
lane so I find it interesting that
people's brains work like that like you
see the full picture like I don't know
that I'm that person so I asked Eva
about her side hustle earlier did y'all
ever do that as a kid have any shimoni
Lawns or anything like that were you
from the hood yeah
me
um I sold candies yeah yeah I created a
whole business proposal for my mom I was
like look Greg came from a single parent
household right me and Mama and I was
like listen LAUSD they took the
chocolate out I need you to front me
twenty dollars I'll give you back
interest all right I'll pay a bill in
the house every month and I made paper
you guys oh my gosh that's so clever
because sugar is good yeah everybody
likes it supply and demand man what was
it yeah
what was yours Jesse uh um
mowing lawns too kind of yeah my parents
would sell burritos and empanadas and
stuff like that whenever my dad would go
to work or to school or whatever it was
so we're always hustling yeah yeah I
have jobs everybody's always like sees
you in what you're doing now and they're
like I'm like no no there were many jobs
before this job and I I think that's
cool I think it's cool actually I have
side hustle I just really have to work
for it because then you appreciate it
you appreciate where you land so
[Music]
[Applause]